hi nice to meet you thank you I'm really
appreciating this color like where did
this come from
this is dojin design bye-bye dojin I
like it what makes you think it it's not
pink but it's like like the color the
color stood out to me so I like it
so let's talk about Riverdale very cool
everyone's buzzing about it
congratulations but mark Consuela's
apparently his son is going to play the
younger version of him what do you think
about that I'm excited I mean it'll be
it'll be fun to work with them I know
Mike's really excited so it's gonna be
it's gonna be interesting they look so
alike so honestly I'm not that surprised
that they would do that because if they
want the most realistic version of it
then it doesn't get more real than that
what can you tell us about the next
season I know you got some teeth the
next season yeah the next season has got
a lot a lot going on for Archie he's on
trial
we're gonna figure out if he goes to
jail or not for the murder of Cassidy
bullet so we're gonna see how that goes
might shake things up with Veronica a
little bit yeah see what happens do you
already know what happens to your
character
are you keeping stuff from us I'm
keeping I'm keeping a little bit from
you I'd be lying if I said I wasn't
Saudi Choice Award it's obviously a
really exciting time is there anybody in
particular that you're looking forward
to seeing looking forward to seeing Cole
know where he is my only friend here so
ready bend or if you had to pick song of
the summer it's either a drape in my
feelings or it's party B I like it
who's your vote for Jeff Buckley he's
not in the votes Jeff Buckley what
you're not gonna you're not gonna pick
one Jeff Buckley
I don't know either of those songs you
don't what do you listen to Jeff Bucket
[Music]
arm band stuff no top 40
no like they're the number one songs
right now yeah I like jazz oh yeah so
who are you pressuring on right now Jeff
Buckley I'm so sorry
I could literally add to it I literally
am though I'm crushing on Jeff Buckley
right now he's an amazing artist I just
started getting into his music about
three four weeks ago and that's all I'm
listening to it was such a tragedy the
way he passed away drowning in the
Mississippi River fully clothed
very mysterious diff very mysterious
artists amazing lyrics but anything
you'd want in an artist he has do you
work for him do you have stocks and his
company like Tommy more I don't I'm just
a big fan of his music I wish that I was
around to watch him play live
and who are you crushing on as a team
it's a teen who am i crushing on I'm not
crushing on anyone who's a team are you
eating right now a team are you how
we'll do right now 21 okay so when you
were a teenager who are you crushing on
who's like pressing on in as a teenager
Jessica Alba okay yeah finally someone
probably Jessica or Jennifer Aniston
filled still would you like totally geek
out if you saw them I probably geek out
a definitely double-take be for sure
I'll be a little bit starstruck yeah